I had prostate cancer a couple years ago
at first I didn't know what was going to
happen so I was scared no I was scared I
didn't know you know that one thing that
it does is it just stops everything in
your life Ben Stiller reveals he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer in jun
2014 life is life right we all have to
deal with the things life throws at us
so you got to have a sense of humor
about it if you can share that I think
that is a huge thing the 50 year old
actor told Howard Stern Tuesday morning
that he credits the controversial PSA
blood test with having saved his life by
detecting the cancer early during a
yearly physical after the interview
Stiller penned a blog post on medium
opening up about the surgery to remove
the tumor taking the PSA test saved my
life literally that's why I am writing
this now there has been a lot of
controversy over the test in the last
few years this is a complicated issue
and an evolving one but in this
imperfect world I believe the best way
to determine a course of action for the
most treatable yet deadly cancer is to
detect it early three months after his
diagnosis Stiller was told he is
cancer-free